[Music]
now to the developing situation in kabul
afghanistan time is running out but the
evacuation of american citizens and
afghan allies continues even after a
suicide bomber killed more than a
hundred people on thursday today the
flag at the white house is at half-staff
in honor of the 13 u.s service members
killed in the bombing the group known as
isis k which counts both the u.s and
taliban among its enemies claimed
responsibility for that attack meanwhile
flights have resumed as the u.s tries to
evacuate as many people as possible
before the august 31st deadline i met
with my commanders this morning first
thing in the morning got a detailed
briefing
about yesterday's attacks and the
measure they're taking to protect our
forces and complete the mission
and we will complete the mission
crowds of afghan civilians are back at
that airport hoping to get on some sort
of flight despite the threat of more
attacks before the withdrawal is
complete president biden has vowed
revenge for that attack but carrying out
a mission against the terrorists will be
harder when u.s forces are no longer in
afghanistan republicans blame president
biden for what they call a failed
withdrawal